Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This one is going to be absolutely amazing.
This piece of work is aimed to help a machine
build a better understanding of images and
3D geometry.
Imagine that we have a large database with
these geometries and images, and we can search
and compare them with arbitrary inputs and
outputs.
What does this mean exactly?
For instance, it can handle a text input,
such as school bus and automatically retrieve
3D models, sketches and images that depict
these kinds of objects.
This is great, but we said that it supports
arbitrary inputs and outputs, which means
that we can use the 3D geometry of a chair
as an input, and obtain other, similar looking
chairs from the database.
This technique is so crazy, it can even take
a sketch as an input and provide excellent
quality outputs.
We can even give it a heatmap of the input
and expect quite reasonable results.
Typically, these images and 3D geometries
contain a lot of information, and to be able
to compare which is similar to which, we have
to compress this information into a more concise
description.
This description offers a common ground for
comparisons.
We like to call these embedding techniques.
Here, you can see an example of a 2D visualization
of such an embedding of word classes.
The retrieval from the database happens by
compressing the user-provided input and putting
it into this space, and fetching the results
that are the closest to it in this embedding.
Before the emergence of powerful learning
algorithms, these embeddings were typically
done by hand.
But now, we have these deep neural networks
that are able to automatically create solutions
for us, that are in some sense, optimal, meaning
that according to a set of rules, it will
always do better than we would by hand.
We get better results by going to sleep and
leaving the computer on overnight than we
would have working all night using the finest
algorithms from ten years ago.
Isn't this incredible?
The interesting thing is that here, we are
able to do this for several different representations:
for instance, a piece of 3D geometry, or 2D
color image, or a simple word, is being embedded
into the very same vector space, opening up
the possibility of doing these amazing comparisons
between completely different representations.
The results speak for themselves.
This is another great testament to the power
of convolutional neural networks and as you
can see, the rate of progress in AI and machine
learning research is absolutely stunning.
Also big thumbs up for the observant Fellow
Scholars out there who noticed the new outro
music, and, some other minor changes in the
series.
If you are among those people, you can consider
yourself a hardcore Two Minute Papers Scholar!
High five!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!